let me start by saying that this is the
last of the
of the colloquia for this semester so
we'll we'll pick things up again in the
fall after this
um so today it's a it's a real pleasure
to have ronald the wolf
from uh the university of amsterdam
um and um uh
uh also who's also he's also a senior
researcher at cwi
uh ronald is um
i think um you know many people here are
doctors of philosophy
ronald is the one person who actually
has a master's in philosophy
uh as in as an actually philosophy
um so he um ronald
has worked extensively on various
aspects of quantum computation including
lower bounds and
computational complexity he um
he actually um also work
you know uh worked on this notion of
dequantization
where you where you prove something via
a quantum argument and then
then uh dequantize it to get the
classical result and
and uh and um
obviously and and also he's worked
extensively on quantum algorithms
including
algorithms for optimization which he'll
tell us about today so
uh ronald welcome and looking forward to
hearing your talk
thanks so much let me share my slides
let's see do you see my slides now
all the slides are nothing but the
slides
uh one of the slides in so you should
now be seeing the full title slide
yeah okay good so let me get started
so this is going to be a survey talk
about quantum algorithms for
optimization problems
um i will not keep track of the chat so
i hope the moderators will interrupt me
if there's an important question that i
need to answer at that point in time
um so what is what is optimization well
the general problem
uh let's let's look at minimization if
we have some function
f therefore it could be general very
general object
and we want to find its minimal value
when x comes from a certain set case
okay it's going to be our feasible set
of allowed solutions the things we can
plug into our function
and then we're supposed to find or at
least approximate the minimal value
and this of course is a basic problem in
analysis in math
it's also a very useful problem in fact
lots of the uses of computers
in industry and elsewhere are of
optimization form
right so here's a simple example finding
the shortest map
finding the shortest routes on a given
map this is a simple example it can be
solved very efficiently
designing a more energy efficient chip
that's also an optimization problem the
function there that you want to
minimize would be the energy usage of
the chip
training your neural network to detect
cats this is of course a massive
application of optimization of all sorts
and forms in the last 10 years
and this is just to illustrate the uh
sort of the versatility and the
usefulness of
of being able to solve optimization
problems
and i want to distinguish two kinds of
optimization namely
the discrete and the continuous setting
for optimization
and the discrete optimization the
variables that you can play with
so that the sort of the the variables
that determine your set k
of feasible solutions are discrete so
think about this as either bits or
integers
right then and you can think here of so
discrete optimization problems include
the shortest path algorithms that i
already mentioned
things like matching algorithms max flow
mean cut in a network
and also
also many np-hard problems in fact very
often if you do if you formulate an
optimization problem and you make it
discrete
so you force your variables to be let's
say binary or integer
your problem becomes np hard and this
includes all sorts of constrained
satisfaction problems like
satisfiability of
boolean formulas traveling salesman
problem integer linear programs
and it should be contrasted with the
case of continuous optimization
where the variables that you can play
with are continuous
so say so typically here your variable
is a vector of n real numbers
could be constrained or could be
unconstrained and here's a bunch of sort
of
algorithms that you could use in the
case of continuous optimization there is
gradient descent which is a very
versatile workhorse of continuous
optimization
they're also much more structured
problems like linear programs
semi-different programs and of course
there's also
non-context optimization which is sort
of the most general
optimization problem you can think of or
you could think of a mix of these so i
actually borrowed here the logo from an
earlier
program of the simon's institute namely
the program that wanted to bridge
between continuous and discrete
optimization
now let me just mention two of these
bridges in fact they will sort of
make a make an appearance later on in
this talk
so one is you can take a discrete
problem a famous example
is finding the maximal cut in a graph
right that's a typical discrete problem
because you can
you want to select a subset of the
vertices of the graph in such a way that
the number of edges that are being cut
by the bipartition is maximized
this is a very discrete problem but
actually the best way to solve it is to
relax it to a continuous
optimization problem and solve this
using an stp solver this gives you the
best approximation that we know how to
find in polynomial time
another interesting bridge example is
the example of laplacian linear system
solving so you can
so solving linear systems so something
of the form lx equals b
where l is a given matrix and b is a
given vector this occurs all over the
place
and typically you need super linear time
to to solve these things so more more
than n squared time if if l is an n by n
matrix
but if l has a special form namely if
it's so-called symmetrically and
diagonally dominant
which means that it sort of corresponds
to a laplacian of the graph
you can actually use discrete techniques
so called graph specification techniques
to sort of
slum your linear system down to be much
sparser and then efficiently solve the
sparser linear system
and this will also resurface at some
point later in my talk
right so this is just setting the stage
of discrete and continuous optimization
and how can quantum computers help
that's of course the sort of the main
purpose of this talk
so i want to claim here that that faster
optimization
is one of the main potential application
areas of quantum computers
right and then of course you would ask
what are the other ones well
i think that the two other main
application areas would be cryptography
and in that case i'm thinking both about
breaking crypto schemes and making
secure other crypto schemes and of
course the most famous of all is the
simulation of quantum systems and i
think these three
are probably the main application areas
of quantum computers for the future
and the good thing about optimization is
that several new quantum algorithms have
been discovered in the last five years
and the purpose of this talk is to
survey these things to survey what we
know
not just the things from the last five
years but i will spend more
sort of attention to those recent
developments
and i'm going to focus here on what i'm
most familiar with because those are the
things i can
sort of semi-competently talk about and
those are provable speed ups
and in particular that means i'm not
going to talk about many things that
have gotten a lot of attention which is
heuristical methods
i'm not going to talk about the
adiabatic algorithm i'm not going to
talk about simulated annealing or
regular annealing
and i'm also not going to talk about
variational quantum algorithms such as
the
the quantum approximate optimization
algorithm due to fatty goldstone goodman
but since erifari will be on the panel i
suspect that later in the pedal
discussion we will also
talk a little bit about sort of more
heuristic algorithms such as these
variational algorithms
and just to set the stage for what might
happen in the pedal discussion let me
just
sort of very briefly say what these
variational algorithms do
the idea is that you you have a low
depth quantum circuit
which is parametrized by a few
parameters for instance a few angles in
the gates in the circuits
and the idea is that that you sort of
want to set these parameters in a way
that would optimize
a certain function so what do you do you
run your circuit you measure the output
or maybe use
repeatedly to approximate the
expectation value of the output
and then you have a classical loop that
adjusts the parameters
to improve the behavior of your circuit
and then you hope to do something useful
and i'm using the word hope here because
not that much provable is known about
the behavior of these variational
algorithms but
one of their sort of useful features is
that they're small enough to be able to
run on current or very near-term
hardware
right but for the purposes of this talk
i'm actually going to bracket these
variational algorithms and i'll talk
about
other kinds of speedups
and i want you i want to mention here
two big caveats for the the algorithms
that i that i will talk about
and um and i think matthias troyer
earlier in this series uh
sort of very clearly made the same
points and i just
wanted to repeat those points basically
to to tell you what are the weaknesses
of the kind of algorithms that i'm going
to talk about
so the first weakness that i of these
algorithms
is that almost all of the optimization
speed ups that quantum computers give
you at least the ones that i will talk
about are
are polynomial typically quadratic or
maybe even less than quadratic
and you could ask yourself is this any
good right and you could say well you
know any speed up is worth having that's
great
of course this is good but there's an
issue here of the
um sort of the the pre-factors that are
hidden in the speed up
right so suppose you have a quantum
algorithm let's say it's grover based
it runs on some search base of size n so
the runtime is order
root n that's how a theorist would write
it but the the order the big o would
hide a large constant because
one quantum operation could be pretty
expensive
right and then you want to compare this
with uh with the classical cost for
solving the same
problem that would be linear in n rather
than square root
but it would have a much smaller
pre-factor right so large c
would be sort of the cost of one quantum
operation and little c would be a cost
of one classical operation
and classical hardware is so good that
this little c is just much much less
than
the big c and you can just calculate
like what is the instance size that you
need before the
sort of the quantum algorithm becomes
faster than the classical algorithm
and this the instant size is the square
of the ratio of these two
pre-factors capital c over little c
raised to the power two
right and this is for quadratic speed up
if your speed up is polynomial with less
than quadratic
it's even worse than this and and then
you want to ask okay so what is what is
this ratio of capital c over little c
how much slower
is a quantum operation than than would
be a classical operation
uh and it's pretty bad i think matthias
troyer in his talk he sort of claimed
that there's like 10 to 12 orders of
magnitude in between
so let's be gentle here and just assume
assume 10 orders of magnitude so if
capital c is 10 to the power 10
bigger than little c you only start
getting a speed
up when your instant size is bigger than
10 to the power 20.
that's that's pretty bad i think 10 to
the power 20 is is not
completely ridiculous but it is pretty
large
so this is one one big caveat right and
i think this this also means that um
that these optimization speed ups
they're not for the nist computer
they're not for the near term
you need you need a computer that's
that's that's big enough to handle such
such large instance sizes that actually
the quadratic speed up despite its large
prefactor can overtake
the classical linear time of course
this 10 to the power 10 here this is
just a very sort of rough estimate it's
it's based on the idea that you need
sort of a certain number of
physical qubits to encode one logical
qubits and that
every quantum operation on those
physical qubits is sort of guided by a
classical computer that spends a number
of operations on
implementing or guiding every quantum
operation and it gives you these large
large orders of magnitude this is not
set in stone i mean i suspect that it
should come down over time
but for now it's certainly true that a
classical operation is much much
cheaper than one quantum operation and
then the second caveat that i want to
mention
is is the issue about how to access data
so so most of the problems i'm going to
talk about they're
they're they start from classical input
classical data and this could be for
instance an input graph
say given as an adjacency matrix or
maybe given as an adjacency list
it could be a matrix in some sdp
description and our quantum algorithm
should be able to access this data in
superposition
right now how do you access data in the
classical computer you would just store
it in a random access memory
right then a random access memory that
stores n bits of information
you can think of this as a piece of
hardware of size roughly n
that you can access in time roughly log
n right and sort of a
quantitative way to think about this is
you can arrange your n
bits as the leaves of a binary tree of
depth login
and then if you want to read one of
those bits you sort of go to the root
of this tree you have login address bits
that chart a path
through the tree towards the leaf that
you want to go to you look up what bit
is stored there and you take it back to
the root
this is really a cartoon picture of how
random access memory works in a classic
computer but it's i think it's good
enough
for the purposes of this talk and a
quantum random access memory should be
somewhat similar
right sometimes people call this a
quantum classical random access memory
because i only care here about
memories that store classical bits but
that i can somehow access in
superposition
so i want to be able to run this unitary
the unitary that that takes i comma zero
to i comma x i so something that allows
me to access the eighth bit of the input
and then it should be coherent meaning
that i could actually run this
my superposition of ice and this is what
i call a quantum ream
and quantum realm has gotten a lot of
bad press recently i think people
a lot of people have been pretty
dismissive about this
i think conceptually there's nothing
really wrong with quantum realm i mean
i think most people would accept that
classical ram is a reasonable concept i
mean we use it every day
uh of course in this crowd quantum
superposition
is also a very reasonable concept
otherwise we wouldn't be here
and if you just put those two things
together you get quantum realm
so i think quantum realm is is at least
a theoretical concept that makes sense
and that might be implementable in the
longer term
and this is very easy for me to say
because i'm not the one who's going to
do the implementing
and particularly in the situation where
your hardware is somewhat noisy this
is this is not easy in any case
the algorithms i'm going to to describe
in the rest of this talk
they will many of them will assume some
sort of qrm access to their
classical input why not can i ask a
question
yeah go ahead is there sorry go ahead
uh so so is there any proposal how to
implement this beyond uh
querying some oracle function when an
article function obviously gives some
kind of pointing line but is there any
proposal how to build something like
that where you could have maybe
an exponentially long time story
information but then it gets out very
quickly
well so i think what you mean by oracle
is just his unitary map right without
actually
saying the article is a quantum ram but
of course that's nothing where you can
actually store stuff so is there any
proposal
you could actually build something like
that where you could so the way i'm
thinking about quantum ream on a high
level is pretty similar to the way i'm
thinking about a classical ram and that
is the
that it's sort of a fixed object of size
n
and and you shouldn't analyze this in
terms of gate complexity because then
you get you should analyze this
in how much time a physical object would
need to travel from the route
to one of the leaves right so so think
of
think of a little train with log n bits
starting at the root
and the little train has log n bits
inscribed inside of it and those log n
bits this they chart a path
that this little train can follow to the
particular leaf that's being addressed
by the login address bits
right so the little train goes down that
path looks like the bit that
is stored here puts it in the face or
puts it into c naughts it into another
qubit and then goes back to the root
is it so can i also write data into this
thing or can i only read data from this
thing maybe that's a way
in some of my algorithms i'm going to
assume that that you can classically
write
so in other words that when you're not
in superposition you can actually decide
okay i'm going to flip the third bit
in this in this round so so is that
proposing how to do that in a
reasonably scaling way i mean a
theoretical proposal that's my question
well it depends on what you mean by
scaling i mean classical ram is not
scaling if you think about it in
in in the circuit model if you write it
as a circuit the number of gates is
going to be order n not order login
and yet people agree that this is not an
issue
so in any case so this little story of a
piece of
hardware of size login that travels down
a path to pick up a bit and then returns
you should somehow be able to do this in
superposition so you could have some
sort of
say some little block of log n qubits
whose position
could be in a superposition and this
could travel down these different paths
and superposition
and i think this makes some sense but
it's going to be terribly hard to
implement it with noise
but i want to move on because i don't
think this should be this okay
shall i move on
okay so do these two big caveats mean
that quantum computers are useless i
would argue no but i would argue that
they're probably not for the near term i
guess i already said this before
if somebody says that they're going to
have some nice commercial applications
of quantum computers based
two years from now it's an optimization
algorithm with a quadratic speed up
i would not put money in that company
but i think for the longer term
these caveats can be overcome
okay so now let me move in to discrete
optimization and discuss
some of the speed ups that we actually
know for problems in discrete
optimization
so the first one is sort of the most
general it's also the
sort of the most boring and that is if
you have a function on a discrete domain
of size
n let's say it maps the numbers one up
to n to the reals
you can find a minimum of this function
in about squared event time this is this
is a very simple
application of grover's quantum search
algorithm which is due to a duran hoyer
right so this is not very exciting but
it is very widely applicable
another example is is finding shortest
paths in graphs
so this is one of the the applications i
mentioned in my first slide
this is a problem that's being sold all
the time you know google maps solves
this
the navigation software in your car
sources
and the classical complexity of this
problem so think about the
the the map as an as an n vertex graph
uh given as a matrix let's say where the
i j entry will give you the distance
between city i
and city j and then you can find the
shortest path in this graph classically
in order n squared time
this is a dijkstra's algorithm which he
actually did when he was at cwi
and you can compare that with quantum
complexity that turns out to be n to the
1.5
so that's a polynomial speed up but it's
not even quadratic
but it is the best you can get this is
what we know about
finding shortest paths there are also
polynomial speed ups for problems like
matching and many other
graph problems
and at least typically unsurprisingly
they use grover's quantum search
algorithm as a black box within a larger
read often redesigned classical
algorithm you typically don't take a
classical algorithm and hit it with
grover you typically
take a classical algorithm sort of
rebalance the different parts and then
apply grover to
whatever search problem is in there
and i want to zoom in on one
recent application of quantum algorithms
to graph problems that give such a
polynomial speed up
where again the main tool is grover's
algorithm but it's really hidden sort of
at the bottom of a large layer of all
sorts of classical tricks
classical tricks that you would not need
in
for classical algorithms and this is the
the case of graph sparsification
uh so graph specification is an
extremely useful tool
for um if you want to do algorithmic
tasks on graphs
and then the picture to keep in mind for
graph specification is you're given this
graph on the left here
it could be pretty dense has lots of
edges and you want to sort of move it to
this graph on the right
which has far fewer edges and yet
retains many of the properties that
that the original graph had and sparse
graphs are good
because they're cheap to store right the
graph is typically stored as a list of
edges if you have fewer edges you need
less space to store your graph
and it's also typically faster to run an
algorithm on a sparse graph than it is
to run an algorithm on a dense graph
let me be a bit more precise so what is
our input our input is a graph let's say
with n vertices and m edges and it's
going to be a weighted graph
so all the edges have some non-negative
weight
and i'm going to assume that this graph
is given as an adjacency list
and what this means is i'm allowed to
ask queries of the form
give me the third neighbor of the fifth
edge or give me the seventh neighbor of
the third edge
this is the type of queries i can ask
right and
and this is not unreasonable if you
store your graph as sort of the
neighbors of vertex one
as a list the neighbors of vertex two as
a list etc
you can make such queries very
efficiently to your graph
right then why am i not using the the
adjacency matrix
format for a graph you know where you
would just have sort of an n by n matrix
it's because if a graph has m edges and
m is much smaller than n squared
then this adjacency list format is a
much more efficient way to represent the
graph
and what is the goal of sparsification
well i already mentioned it you want to
take your graph g
which may have many edges and you want
to reduce the number of edges
significantly while preserving
many of its properties and you want to
do that efficiently
and what does it mean to preserve many
of its properties so
the kind of things that we will preserve
of the graph will be spectral properties
and the spectral properties of the graph
are are very nicely
codified in in an n by n matrix that's
called the graph laplacian and the graph
laplacian of the graph g
this is an n by n matrix and it's going
to be the weighted sum
of the laplacians of the individual
edges in your graph so it's going to be
a sum of m
different matrices weighted
and the laplacian of one particular edge
let's say the edge i j
that's going to be this this rig one
matrix here
um and i don't want to really give an
intuition for why laplacian is a good
representation for a graph
but it is a very natural one and if you
prefer to think about the adjacency
matrix then
uh let's say in the case of an
unweighted graph the laplacian is just
a diagonal matrix that has the degrees
on its diagonal
minus the adjacency matrix and this is a
very good
linear algebraic way to represent your
graph
and what is it that we want to preserve
in sparsification it's it's
essentially the properties of the
laplacian so here's a technical
definition
so i'm starting with this graph g and i
want to find another graph h
whose set of edges is a subset of the
original set of edges hopefully a much
smaller subset
i'm allowed to re-weigh the graph so i'm
allowed to change the weight function w
and the number of vertices remains the
same so i start and end with and
vertices i just want to have fewer edges
between those 30 sets just like in this
picture at the top of my slide
and the property i want to preserve is
that for every
vector x of n variables the
quadratic form of the laplacian of g
and h should be essentially the same
with respect to that vector x so this is
a pretty strong requirement for every
n-dimensional vector x i want x
laplacian of g times x to be essentially
the same within a multiplicative factor
of one plus or minus epsilon
to the laplacian of h
and l g and l h are not going to be the
same matrix
how could they be because h is going to
be much much sparser than g
and yet somehow we can we can preserve
all these quadratic forms here
and this is a pretty powerful thing and
just to illustrate one example suppose
you were to start with the complete
graph
uh let's say the the end clique then a
typical example of a sparsification
would be an expander graph
an expander graph is a graph that has a
constant degree so its number of edges
is order n and it it shares this
property here so
so all of the quadratic forms in the
laplacian are preserved
right so you can really think of an
expander graph here sort of the poor
man's version
of the complete graph
now why do we care about preserving
these quadratic forms
i'm sorry let me first say that that
that's specification is actually
it's possible and it's efficient so it's
for every given graph g
you can always sort of cut down the
number of edges to be linear in
n the number of vertices you for
concreteness just think of epsilon here
as a small constant something like 1
over 100 or 1 over a thousand
right so then you go from m edges to
order n edges
and that's as small as it gets because
if you had fewer than n edges your graph
becomes disconnected
and the good thing is we can also find
such a specification in near linear time
so it exists and you can find it very
efficiently
this is o tilde by the way this ignores
some block factors you can think of this
as essentially linear time in the input
length
right because the input length is
proportional to m as an adjacency list
you're just storing a list of edges
so this is essentially linear in the
input length
and this is all classical and it has
lots of applications
including for instance very efficiently
getting
approximate min cut or max cut in a
graph
because if you look at this this this
property that's being preserved here and
you plug in the special case where x is
a zero one vector
right so you can think of a zero one
vector x is sort of specifying
a subset of the vertices but then it
turns out that
this left hand side here this is just
the value of the cut
between the subsets specified by your
zero one vector and its complement
and so what this is saying is for every
possible cut in g
the corresponding value of that cut in h
is almost the same
multiplicatively related by let's say
1.001
it's almost the same right so if you
want to approximate the min cut in your
graph
and you don't like dense graphs what do
you do you first specify it
and then you run a min cut algorithm on
the sparsified graph
and similarly with with mexico mexico is
a very different problem because it's np
hard
while mean code is in polynomial time
but the best possible approximation you
can get in
for max cuts is done in this way you
take your graph you specify it
and then you solve the sdp for the
sparsified graph
the gomes williams and sdp
and another thing and i think this was
really the main driving force
in the development of sparsification is
to very efficiently solve these
laplacian linear systems that i
mentioned before as a bridge between
continuous and discrete
optimization so you can solve if i give
you a linear system lx equals b
let's say l your matrix has m non-zero
entries
you could solve that linear system in
linear time in m that's pretty good
and it uses sparsification as a
subroutine
and this development actually netted
stillman and tang the 2015 google price
this was viewed as a very important
development and these two people were
kind of pivotal in the development
right and this is all classical what i
said here i basically just described
what cross specification is
why we want to do it and that you can
efficiently solve it classically
in linear time in the length of the
input
now of course i want to talk about
quantum so what's my next slide
obviously it's going to be a faster
quantum algorithm to do specification
and let me just emphasize here that the
output here is classical this is not
something like the hhl algorithm where
i return the answer as a quantum state
the answer is just a classical
description of the sparsified graph
and this was the work done by silvan
operas and myself
last year actually most of the work was
done by simon
so we give a quantum algorithm that
finds uh an absolute spectral sparsifier
h in sub linear time
essentially square root m and again
think of epsilon as a small constant
here
right then this is a polynomial speed up
for instance if you start
with a pretty dense graph where m is
like n squared
then we reduce the complexity from a
classical n squared to a quantum into
the 1.5
again polynomials speed up but even less
than quadratic but it turns out that
this is the best you can get we also
proved that this is optimal
in m and then in epsilon
and we got very similar speed ups for
these these applications that i
mentioned before mint approximate min
cut
approximate max cuts solving laplacian
systems we can all do this in sub linear
time
um and let me very briefly sketch how
our quantum algorithm works
um so its starting point is a classical
iterative sparsifier due to goodison 2
from 2016.
and the idea is so this this uh
iterative sparsifier this works in a
logarithmic number of iterations
and every iteration sparsifies your
graph a little bit more
so it's not like you go from m edges to
order n edges in one step
you sort of cut the number of edges in
half in every iteration
and after a logarithmic number of
iterations you're down to the minimal
number of edges
and each iteration of this goodis two
sparsifier what it does
is it first identifies a small set of
important edges in your graph
the ones you definitely want to keep in
your sparsifier this is going to be
roughly order n
edges think of that as a very small
fraction of the edges
and they identify these important edges
by finding a few spanners in the graph
so a spanner is sort of a sub graph that
preserves distances and it's very sparse
so you can find a few spanners in your
graph now you could do that classically
in linear time
or the order m and then of course you
still have almost all of your edges left
because you only took out a very small
fraction of them so what do you do
you just sample of the remaining edges
you sample half of them and you throw
the rest away
and that means that one iteration of
this goodies to sparsifier it kind of
sparsifies by half
it goes from m edges to roughly m over
two edges
next iteration goes to roughly m over
four edges
and this means that after a logarithmic
number of iterations
you've actually found a good h so an h
that has order n
edges left and this is all pretty
efficient this works essentially
classically in linear time until the m
and our quantum speed up uses two
different tools
one is we give a better quantum
algorithm to find these spanners in the
graph
classically this takes o tilde m time
which is as good as it gets quantumly we
can reduce this to
square root mn
and last but not least we we find the
final set of edges so at the end of
these different iterations we find those
using grover's algorithm and you might
wonder how does this come up
and the reason is we have to keep a very
intricate implicit representation of our
intermediate graphs
right classically if you think about
this you start with a graph within
which has m edges and you sort of reduce
to another graph that has m over two
edges another graph that has more for
four edges etc
and classically you have enough time and
space to keep those in memory
right your classical algorithm is
supposed to work in oat till the end
time
it has enough time to just sort of write
down all these intermediate graphs
we don't have that time in the quantum
case because we want a sublinear
algorithm so we need to go through a lot
of tricks using all sorts of implicit
representations
using k-wise random strings to sort of
downsample our graph in every iteration
and what we end up with after
logarithmically many iterations is a
very implicit
representation of the sub graph h
and then we use a final graph research
over this implicit representation to
actually pick out explicitly
what are the edges that we're going to
retain for our sparsifier
so that this picture sort of illustrates
this for the case where you start with
the complete graph
so this is the g on the left here you
find a few spanners those are the red
edges
you downsample the others and you get to
this graph here
in this in this smaller graph with fewer
edges you again find a small number of
spanners
those edges you keep in your sparsifier
if you don't sample the rest so you go
down to m over four edges etc
right and at the end of the day there's
this implicit representation left that
has only roughly n over epsilon squared
edges left
and we use grover search to find those
and there's like i said there's several
layers of classical stuff here
that are needed to make this work
including all this ky's
independence which you don't need in the
classical case so on the one hand
sort of the main quantum subroutine is
grover which we apply in multiple places
but on top of that we need to do a lot
of classical work
that classically would not be necessary
this just to illustrate that you don't
just sort of hit things
with grover you have to do a lot more
work to get these speed ups
okay so i guess this is what i wanted to
say about discrete
but there's one more slide i wanted to
say about discrete optimization that's
of course what all the journalists and
startups are after quantum speed-ups for
np-hard optimization problems
um polynomial speedups for np-hard
optimization problems are very feasible
we have lots of those
right sort of the canonical one is you
can speed up the satisfiability problem
suppose i give you a boolean formula
that has n boolean variables x one and
two x and
you you can think of this just as a
search space of size two to the end
every truth assignment is a string of n
bits if you wanna
see if there's there exists a satisfying
assignment to your formula five
one thing you could do is you could just
brute force search over all the truth
assignments
and of course you can speed this up
using grover right i don't think i'm
seeing anything very surprising here
and this is the best that we know for
things like satisfiability
and for many other
np-hard optimization problems
[Music]
even this doesn't work like you can't
just sort of treat this as a brute force
search problem and hit it with grover
like a slightly more interesting problem
is three set
right you could hit this with grover you
get a algorithm that takes time square
root of two to the n
that's actually slower than the best
classical algorithm that we know
so classically there's this very nice
random book algorithm due to shining
which solves the three sub problem in
four thirds to the end
that's better than what rover gives you
four thirds is less than the square root
of two
unfortunately in this case we can use
grover in a slightly more subtle way
you could still sort of look at
scheding's algorithm
and do a search over so you can think of
shoning's algorithm as
a polynomial time algorithm that has a
success probability
three quarters to the end right so if
you repeat it four thirds to the end
many times you find a satisfying
assignment
and this is something we know how to
speed up quadratically using something
called
amplitude amplification right so you can
hit shining's algorithm with amplitude
amplification and you still get your
quadratic speed up
compared to the best classical algorithm
and i want to
mention briefly two more general
techniques that you could use for
attacking nbr problems one is
actually montenero's quadratic speeded
for backtracking
so backtracking is a very general tool
that you can use to sort of
slightly more cleverly search through an
exponential search base and you can you
can speed this up quadratically
and another general fairly general tool
is polynomial speedups for dynamic
programming
this is due to the unbinders group
again these are polynomial speedups
they're even less than quadratic
and one interesting application here is
the best algorithm we know for the
traveling salesman problem
uh this is called the health carp
algorithm it takes time roughly 2 to the
pm
and you can speed this up hormonally to
roughly 1.7 to the other
and this is not super impressive of
course but um
there are already subtle things you
could you would you want to do here
because the
if you just hit the traveling salesman
problem with grover you get nothing
right traveling salesman is the problem
of finding a route
in an n vertex graph and the route
should go through every vertex
exactly once and there's n minus one
factorial such different routes so of
course you could hit this with grover
solve the problem in square root of n
factorial many steps
that's much much worse than this
classical health card algorithm
and for a long time we didn't even know
any speed up for tsp despite what the
journalists sometimes tell you
and so at least it was sort of
gratifying that we can get some
polynomial speed up
for dsp by speeding up this health card
dynamic programming algorithm
i think this is currently still the best
that we know we don't even have a
quadratic speed up for solving
travelling salesman problem
i'll mention that as one of my open
problems
um and and these polynomial speed ups
they're probably that's probably as good
as it gets
we don't expect uh super polynomial or
even exponential speed ups
and the reason is if you view
satisfiability just as an unstructured
search problem
then this grover speed up is optimal
this was shown by
bennett brassard bernstein long time ago
and then of course you could tell me
well you know this is not an
unstructured search problem
like if i give you a boolean formula
there's a lot there's structure
to the set of satisfying assignments
right so use that structure
and i would be happy to do so but i have
no clue how to do it and neither do we
know how to do it in the classical case
we don't know how to use the structure
in npr problems and this is also the
reason why we believe that b
is different from np and even stronger
statements like the exponential time
hypothesis
and then and the same applies to to in
the quantum case like brute force is not
going to solve npr problems efficiently
we don't know how to use the structure
to get anything much better
i guess this ends what i wanted to say
about the case of discrete optimization
so let me move on to continuous
optimization
i see lots of stuff in the chat by the
way so moderators feel free to interrupt
me if there's anything that needs
attention
uh we were just having a separate
discussion uh okay
yeah thanks i hope you guys are having
fun
good so continuous optimization um let
me first talk about gradient descent
because that's really kind of the sort
of the
the swiss army knife or the workhorse of
um
of um optimization so what's gradient
descent i'm sure
most people have seen it before um it's
some iterative method
to find the min at least a local minimum
of some function f
so think of f as a function that takes a
vector of n real numbers to one real
number
so what do you do if you want to find
the local max local minimum
you start at some point here you compute
the gradients so sort of the
the vector of derivatives and you go
down
negatively along the gradient because
locally this is the direction of
steepest descent so if you sort of
greedily want to minimize your function
you want to move down the gradient by
some some amount
right then you get to a new point you
compute the gradient you move down
further etc
it's a very simple idea and it will
typically take you to a
a local minimum but not always but it
will often take you to a local minimum
now if you're lucky like you are in this
picture and you the function you want to
minimize is convex
then a local minimum is actually a
global minimum
but even in many cases where your
function is not not convex
it's still useful to be able to find a
local minimum in many cases a local
minimum is actually pretty good
for instance this is true for when
you're training neural networks
so okay so this is basically what i
described before this is just gradient
descent
you start at time zero take some initial
point x0
you compute the gradient that's the
vector of n partial derivatives
evaluated at your current point
gives you the direction of steepest
ascent or steepest descent
and you just go down by some some step
size eta
so you move down a little bit right and
typically this eta here can actually
depend on t
you typically want to have large step
sizes initially so you make big jumps
towards your optimum
and once you once you're further down
the line for bigger t
and you're closer to the optimum you
want to take smaller steps so that you
don't overshoot
so very often this eta actually scales
like one over t
or one over root t or something like
that
and then you just repeat until you're
happy
and this this method is just enormously
useful it's used all over the place it's
studied
very extensively very often there's
pretty fast convergence this is a good
method
and we want to speed it up and in some
cases quantum computers can speed it up
not so much by reducing the number of
iterations but by just speeding up the
cost of one iteration
right if you look at this algorithm here
the the most expensive step is clearly
computing the gradient
which is an n-dimensional vector and you
want to play in every iteration you have
to compute this gradient again
either exactly or approximately and in
some cases quantum computers can
compute this gradient much better much
faster
so i want to sketch this in one slide
and this is due to stephen jordan in
2004.
and let me sketch it for the case where
um
so jordan actually assumed that that f
is approximately linear
around the point where you want to
evaluate the gradients right so let's
say we want to evaluate the
the vector of partial derivatives the
gradient at some point z
let's assume for notational simplicity
that z is the zero point
right then the assumption that f is
approximately linear means you can write
it like this
right then i'm going to use these approx
symbols all over the place this is just
a sketch it's not very rigorous
and if you have something that's close
to the linear function then
what is the gradient well the gradient
is essentially these vectors of linear
coefficients here
a1 and 2am
so this is this is what the vector that
you want to extract efficiently
and suppose we we can compute our
function in the phase
so suppose we have a an oracle that
takes
cat x that x would be an input to your
function
so let's say a vector of n real numbers
in finite precision
and suppose we can compute the value at
f
of f at that point and we can put it in
the face
right if you just can compute the value
of f in a bunch of bits that's good
enough because you can put that in the
phase and uncompute
so this is not an unreasonable
assumption that we can do this
now so here's a simple quantum algorithm
to extract
this vector a1 up to am to extract the
gradient
at the point z so we first
take a finite grid of equally spaced
points around
each entry zj right remember z is the
is the point at which we want to
evaluate the gradient
and we set up a uniform superposition
where every coordinate of x
sort of ranges uniformly over that grid
this is very easy to compute on the
quantum computer
and then we compute in superposition we
compute this function value in the phase
and because the function value is
essentially a linear linear function
some some nice factorization happens so
first of all this a0
here is sort of comes out of the sum
it's a global phase and it doesn't
matter
the other parts it really very nicely
factors into end pieces
so approximately what you have created
now is global phase which is irrelevant
and then an enfold tensor product
where each each of the the product
states is essentially
the fourier transform of the number aj
that you're trying to extract so what do
you do now you just
separately to each of these n registers
you do an inverse fourier transform
and you get the numbers a1 up to a n
right and this is of course nothing else
but the the bernstein vazirani algorithm
but done in real space instead of in
binary space
right bernstein vazirani algorithm is
exactly the same thing but it recovers
the coefficients of a linear function
over f2
instead of a linear function over the
reals this is a very simple trick
and and we should notice here that uh
the time complexity
is not constant here but the number of
calls you make to f
is constant so if you want to compute a
gradient of a pretty expensive function
this can actually be a very good thing
and there's an issue here the issue is
in this approximation symbol here
like every function that's sort of
somewhat smooth of course
if you look at look very closely around
zed it's going to be very linear around
that
right because the higher order terms of
its if it's taylor series they don't
matter too much
but maybe you have to be extremely close
to z when you're
evaluating your function in order to
pick up this linear behavior
that's going to be expensive
it will also require computing your
function f with a very high precision
right so there was a subsequent paper
after jordan's paper by guillen
shalom and for the case where f is not
so close to a linear function but maybe
it's close to a somewhat higher degree
polynomial and they did essentially the
same thing with
with higher order interpolation formulas
so when f
is not well approximated by linear but
by a low degree polynomial
and then you could do pretty similar
tricks the number of function
evaluations is no longer constant but
it's still a lot better than what it
would be classically
so this is a pretty useful general trick
to
compute gradients at least approximately
compute gradient
the next thing i want to talk about is
is another workhorse of continuous
optimization and that's linear programs
so what is a linear program a linear
program is something that
that maximizes or minimizes a linear
function in this case i start with a
maximizing linear program
and the variable you can play with here
is a is an n-dimensional real vector
so you have real real numbers of x one
up to x and this is this is what you can
move around
this is what you can play with and you
want to
maximize this linear function right so c
is a fixed vector here it gives you sort
of the costs
um and c transpose x this is just sum
over i
c i x i it's a weighted weighted linear
combination of the xi's this is the
thing you want to
maximize and you have a number of linear
constraints given by these vectors aj
so for for j running from 1 up to m
m is the number of linear constraints
you wanted j
transpose x is at most bj and you also
want your vector x to be non-negative
this is a canonical form for linear
programming
right so the input is the vector c that
specifies your objective function
the vectors j and b and the numbers b j
that specify your linear constraints
and then x is your variable that you can
try to maximize over
and this has been a very important tool
in in continuous optimization since at
least the 1940s
this is due to the simplex methods which
is um
exponential time in the worst case but
pretty efficient in practice
and you can even do exponential
polynomial time
in the worst case by for instance the
ellipsoid method which was
invented by kachiyan or at least applied
by katja onto linear programming in the
late 70s
so this is a very important general tool
it can be used to optimize all sorts of
processes in factories etc
the way you sort of distribute your
resources over different processes
very often you can capture these things
with linear programs and you can then
efficiently optimize
and you can generalize linear program to
something called semi-definite programs
and here what you do is you just replace
the the non-negative n-dimensional
vector x
which is the variable in an lp you
replace it by an n by n
positive semi-definite matrix which i
will denote by capital x
and everything else remains basically
the same
so the trace of a fixed matrix c times x
this is really just a linear combination
of all the
n squared entries of the matrix x so
it's still a linear function that you're
trying to optimize
over your variable capital x and
similarly you can have linear
constraints
specified by matrices aj and numbers bj
and the constraints that x in the lp
needs to be a negative vector is
replaced by the constraint that
that capital x in the sdp needs to be a
psd matrix
and just like for lps there is a
beautiful duality theory for these
things
so under mild assumptions this
maximization program is equivalent to
this minimization program
and somehow the constraints and the
variables change place here
so on the left you had an n by n
variable matrix you get m
constraints and on the right you have an
m dimensional variables vector y
and you have one big psd constraints
on n by n matrices
and for my next slides it's going to be
convenience to put some trace upper
bound on x so that x
is not unbounded i'm going to assume
that the trace of x
is is at most r i'm adding this as a
constraint to my primal program so the
program on the left is called the primal
the program sorry the program on the
on the left is called the primal the one
on the right is called the dual so i'm
adding this constraint here
to the primal just to make it a bounded
problem
of course this also affects the dual it
affects it in this way so i'm just
adding a little bit of stuff to the dual
here is to make a nice
primal dual pair again um and the good
thing about these stps is they look a
lot more complicated than lps
to some extent they are they actually
have a lot
more expressive power i already
mentioned this sdp
based algorithm of googons and
williamson to
approximate the maximal cut in a graph
as well as we can in polynomial time
the good thing is it's still solvable
efficiently
for instance using the ellipsoid method
that was also used for lps
and there's a technical issue here that
you might not get
to the exact optimal solution so we
typically want to approximate the
optimal value here up to some
additive error epsilon
and one way to do that is to just sort
of add an additional constraint to the
dual where you say
i want that b t y is at most some number
alpha
if you do this and you check for
feasibility of this dual you're actually
deciding
whether the optimal value is at most
alpha or not if the
optimal value is less than alpha then
your modified dual is still going to be
feasible and by varying alpha
these feasibility problems then allow
you to do binary search to find the
optimal value
right and again this is all classical i
want to talk about quantum
um so there's this this recent
development from the last few years that
there are
better quantum sdp solvers and they they
they start from something called
the arura kale state base over
um and i probably made a mistake with
this slide in the sense that i tried to
cram
the classical sdp solver as well as its
quantization into one slide so this is
going to be a very dense slide
and i apologize in advance for that but
it has the advantage that i don't have
to leave back and forth while explaining
how to quantize the aurora kill
stp solder right so
if you're epsilon the the additive error
you allow in approximating the optimal
value
is kind of big i think think one over a
thousand
shouldn't be exponentially small should
it be polynomial small but let's say
small constant
then the best classical sdp solver is is
the multiplicative weights method of
around kali
and you should think of this as an
iterative method to
to sort of do binary search on the
optimal value by deciding feasibility
that's what i sketched at the end of the
last slide
so we're sort of adding a constraint to
the dual problem saying that the optimal
value is less than alpha and we're
checking if that's feasible or not
if it's feasible the optimal value is
less than alpha we can continue
our binary search if it's not feasible
the optimal value is bigger than alpha
and we can continue our binary search
and the idea of this aurora kayla
solver is just sort of bouncing back and
forth between imperfect solutions of the
primal and the dual
and it turns out that this converges
amazingly quickly
so we're going to start here let me
briefly remind you of what the primal
and the dual look like
so i had this trace constraint on x and
for x position i'm just going to put
this r equal to one
right so so let's start simple let's
start with sort of an attempt at a
feasible solution for the primal let's
just take
the matrix identity over n uh at least
it's psd and it's it's its trace is one
so those two constraints are satisfied
and now the thing is that you can derive
from this sort of purported
attempt at a feasible solution for the
primal you can derive a very
relaxed version of the dual problem and
this relaxed version is just going to be
a linear program with only two
constraints
and it looks like this and this looks
kind of complicated so let me just sort
of point out the different pieces here
this is the same objective function we
already had
before this is this new constraint that
we're adding
which is sort of claiming that the
optimal value is at most alpha
and this here this is just one linear
constraint
so i've kind of replaced the matrices aj
by the trace inner product between x0
and aj
so what we have here this is just one
linear constraint and here's another
linear constraint so this is a very
simple lp now
there's only two linear constraints
ignoring the non-negativity conditions
and let me very quickly browse back to
the to the dual to show you where this
comes from and why this is a relaxation
of the dual
right if you look at this big psd
constraint that's happening in the dual
here
this statement here is equivalent to
saying that for every psd matrix x
if i take trace inner product of the
left hand side with that x
and trace inner product of the right
hand side with that same x i get an
inequality between numbers
and if that inequality is true for every
possible psd matrix x
that's equivalent to this is constrained
here
and now i'm going to relax this by
saying i only wanted inequality to hold
for the particular x0
that i started with for my reported
primal solution so i'm sort of taking
the inner product here
between aj and i and c with this matrix
x0
and that that's exactly what gives me
this linear constraint here
right and this is no longer a linear
constraint between matrices this is one
linear inequality
involving the real numbers yj
um and it's possible that this very
simple lp is infeasible
if it's infeasible i know that the
optimum must be bigger than alpha and i
can stop and i can continue
my binary search with another value for
alpha
if on the other hand this relaxed dual
has a solution a vector y that is a
solution i can use that to
define this matrix h
i'm not going to explain the intuition
of why we're defining this h but this h
can then be used
to define a new attempt at a primal
feasible solution
x1 and this is going to be e to the
minus eta
eta times h0 and this proportional
symbol here means i'm going to divide by
the trace so that it's it's
the trace of x1 is 1 as it should be
this again induces another
relaxed dual again with only two linear
constraints which is either infeasible
and then i'm done
or i can solve it if i can solve it this
gives me an update for the matrix h
so i need a new matrix h1 this i can use
to define my next point x2 etc
and this sort of bounces back and forth
between all sorts of
imperfect primal solutions imperfect
dual solutions
and then a miracle occurs the miracle of
the multiplicative weights methods
um if if none of these relaxed duals is
actually infeasible
then this will converge in roughly log
many iterations this is going to
converge to an epsilon optimal primal
feasible solution this is kind of
amazing
and i've seen it's already nine so i
will probably have to speed up a little
bit
um and this is all classical right this
is an explanation of this aroracali
classical stp solver and then in 2016
brandow and sword they had the great
idea to interpret this thing in quantum
terms
right because what are these x's here
these x's
they are n by n psd matrices of trace
one
right we know these things as density
matrices
mixed states so you can actually
interpret these x ts
as log n qubit quantum states
and they're not just arbitrary log n
qubit quantum states like any physicist
will tell you that what is this thing
here
this thing is a thermal state with
respect to hamiltonian h1 and inverse
temperature eta
and we have quantum algorithms to
prepare
such states also known as gibbs states
so you can prepare these these primal
solutions
as quantum states as log n qubit next
states
you can then use those quantum states to
sort of approximate these numbers here
that give you
your relaxed dual and so on
and if you put these things together you
actually get a faster quantum algorithm
yeah there's a question in the chat for
the classical part by david
are the primal solutions feasible at
each step
they're not no you sort of converge to
something that's almost feasible after
about logarithmically many iterations
in fact what you really do is you you
run this thing for order log n times and
you take the average of the different
axes
you tweak it a little bit and then you
get a primal feasible solution
great thanks
yeah so this was the the great idea of
brenda awards for this was then
improved by a bunch of people including
myself and my students and also krav
daos for
the maryland group and currently the
best result is by uh
from alberto and gillian and they showed
that if you start with
s sparse sdps and this means that the
constrained matrices and the objective
matrix c
that each row and each column have its
most s non-zero entries
you could solve these stps you can get
an absolute optimizer
in this time here and
don't stare at this for too long the
main thing to observe here is that this
is
like a very nice polynomial speed up in
terms of m
n and actually the dependence on epsilon
is a little bit worse than classically
so this is a good algorithm
for relatively large epsilon
so this is what i wanted to say about
sdps
i probably need about between five and
ten minutes
should i rush or what shall i do
um if you could if you could keep it to
five
five minutes that should be fine okay
good let me try
okay so lps and sdps are special cases
of general convex optimization and i
want to sketch here two
very general results that are known
about
about quantum speedups for general
convex optic problems
so the idea is you're given a convex
function f over
convex set k of feedable solutions and
you want to
to minimize it and let's say up to
additive error epsilon
it's typically too hard to optimize
these things perfectly
and i have a positive and a negative
result about this and given that these
are trying times i want to start with a
positive result
and the positive result is that um so
classically
you can ask yourself what kind of access
will i have to this convex set and
there's many different ways to access
it you could for instance maybe you can
ask membership queries
or maybe you can ask separation queries
a separation query is something like a
membership period in k but
if your point is outside of k then your
oracle also tells you a separating
hyperplane so it gives you extra
information
you can also think of optimization
access to k that's really the problem
you want to solve so there the input
would be a linear function and the
output would be a minimizer of that
linear function over k
and all these things have long been
known to be polynomial time equivalents
and this was done by
gretchen lothas and striver in the 80s
and the good thing is that some of these
reductions between these different types
of excess you can really speed them up
in the quantum case for instance you can
implement a separation oracle
using only a logarithmic number until
the one
runs for a membership query and that's
an exponential speed up
over this is in fact one of the few
exponential speed ups in this whole talk
and it's unfortunately only an
exponential speed of inquiry complexity
not in time complexity
and if you can do separation queries
very efficiently you can also do
optimization very efficiently because
it's known that with order n
separation queries you can do
optimization so this this induces then a
quadratic speed up over the best
classical
optimization algorithm and then the
negative result is
so it's known that um classical gradient
descends
um for a function that's g
lipschitz so that's kind of smooth from
a point that's a distance r
from the unknown optimizer needs this
many
queries to a gradient oracle to a first
order oracle
and this is known to be optimal and
there's a very recent result by
garc kottari netrapali and sharif that
even in the quantum case is adoptable
so there's no sort of generic black box
speed up
quantum speed up for gradient descent
this is my penultimate slide before the
summary so i also wanted to say
a little bit more about non-convex
optimization again a very recent
interesting result it was in qip this
year
so if g is not context if you're outside
of the convex opt
region you have the problem of saddle
points so gradient descent sort of tries
to go towards a local minimum and it
kind of stops when the gradient has
become zero
if your function is convex this is a
local minimum and even a global minimum
if your function is not convex things
like this picture could happen i don't
know if you see the red dot here but
it is at a subtle point of the of the
function
the gradient is going to be zero at that
point but it's clearly not even at the
local minimum
and there's classical ways to sort of
escape from several points
and the way that works is you basically
do gradient descent for a few steps
and then you start shaking your point a
little bit to escape from the saddle
point it's somewhat similar to what
happens in simulated annealing
but you can analyze it rigorously and
generally
and lee just this year they showed
that you can speed this up somewhat by
by replacing the classical shaking by a
very nice
quantum shaking that's based on
hamiltonian simulation
and last but not least i want to say a
little bit about the hhl algorithm
because
you might think why on earth have i not
mentioned the hhl algorithm yet
it should be super useful for
optimization
right so what does hhl do i give you a
matrix a i give you a vector b
h l gives you the solution vector x of
the linear system as a quantum state
so the vector of amplitudes of this
state cat x this is going to be the
solution to your linear system
and this should be very useful and i
know of two
examples in optimization where this has
been applied um
one is a polynomial speed up for finite
element methods due to montenarro and
palestine
finite element methods are a way to sort
of solve a discretized version of a
system of differential equations
so they use hhl right the headline of
hhl is that it
sometimes gives you an exponential speed
up but if you do it properly in this
case montenarro and paluster actually
end up with a polynomial speed up
and the other example i wanted to
mention is a quantum interior point
method
due to kirinitis and prakash interior
point methods are one of the most
important
sort of general solvers for convex
optimization problems
they're they're iterative and in each
iteration they solve a linear system
so-called newton's system so kerenitz
and prakash what do they do they use hhl
to solve this linear system
but then something very nasty happens
they they sort of so
you get sort of the the delta of your
point you get it as a quantum state
but you actually want to be able to
classically update your points so
they solved this newton system using all
the power of quantum computing
and then they have to measure the state
multiple times in order to actually
classically learn
how to how to modify their state sorry
how to modify their current point in the
interior point algorithm
so this is sort of interesting but it's
also somewhat unsatisfactory
and it's also one of my open questions
so let me
go to the summary uh i emphasize this i
think faster optimization is one of the
main potential applications
emphasis on the word potential here
because of these issues that i mentioned
before
right quadratic speedups are not great
you need large instance size
qrm is an issue we have many speedups
usually polynomial i went over some of
them in this talk
and let me end with a few open problems
so one is i think
we should try to find better quantum
interior point methods
uh i think this kirinitis prakash
algorithm is a good start but it's not
it's probably not the best answer we can
give
if you look at quantum speed ups for
iterative methods they typically improve
the cost per iteration
that's true for these these stp solvers
that i mentioned
it's also true for other things that i
didn't mention like quantum speed ups
for boosting and matrix scaling
and it would be very nice to find
examples where we can also speed up the
number of iterations like reduce the
number of iterations i'm not aware of
any of those
can we solve the traveling salesman
problem with the quadratic speedup
lots of journalists say that we can
solve tsp and polynomial time we don't
even have a quadratic speed up yet
and last one is something like
approximate max flow in weighted graphs
so there's a very nice classical
development in algorithms that uses
electrical networks
and laplacian solvers to efficiently
approximate max flow and the question is
whether we can speed this up get it down
to sublinear time
so with the policies for going over time
this ends my talk
thanks ronald that was a it was a
fantastic
survey of quantum optimization methods
so
um let me see if there are any if there
any questions
anurag or chinmay yeah so one question
from the chat is
uh do you have any opinions on the
variation algorithms of this qaoa
yeah i mean i i sort of consciously sort
of bracketed them at the start of my
talk
i don't know too much about them i know
that an enormous amount of
people are working on this stuff like
most of the quantum algorithms that you
see
appear on quant phase they tend to be
variational algorithms
i think part of the reason is it's easy
to write a paper about variational
algorithms
right you just have some heuristic you
implement it on a five qubit ibm
computer it doesn't really mean very
much
so i think it's interesting because we
can experiment with them but i
i have not seen strong indications that
these things really speed up
over even very simple classical
algorithms so
matt hastings has a nice paper where he
has a sort of a
class of classical local search
algorithms that perform at least as well
as
things like qaoa i think the jury is out
on the usefulness of variational
algorithms in optimization that is
i'm all for variational algorithms in
chemistry i think something like vqe is
a very good idea
not sure if i fully answer that question
but
i hope so uh thanks thanks here so
marika says that was very helpful
and uh another another question is would
there be
uh the question is about devda would
there be quantum speed ups for
projected gradient methods for
constraint optimization problems
uh yeah that's a good good point here so
the way i i sketched radiant descent is
a
sort of unconstrained problem where you
just move in a direction of gradient you
don't have to worry about feasibility
but of course it's possible that your
gradient step takes you outside of your
set k
of feasible solutions and then you have
to project it back
um probably some of the things that i
mentioned like these stp solvers you can
probably think of them as
projected gradient descent but i don't
know enough about it to be
to be certain here it's actually a
pretty nice idea right because you could
use quantum measurements to try to do
the projection
i'm not sure if there's any like deep
work on this
good thanks so so much do you have time
for two more questions i think there's
one on the chair
uh yeah let's let's do uh at least okay
one more question oh one more yeah so
there's one question from q a uh by
alessandro luongo
uh uh do you think the
quantum approach for zero sun games is
any relevant for lp optimization
or is there is the error dependence too
big
uh so i mentioned these these stp
solvers which have a certain complexity
and there are actually slightly better
quantum lp
solvers so if you look at a special case
of sdps where the matrices are diagonal
you get back to linear programs
and the best quantum algorithm for
solving lps is based on these zero-sum
games
and then it's it's asymptotic complexity
is slightly better than what i mentioned
for general sdps
great thanks
great okay well uh
great thanks uh ronald so let's um uh
let's move on to the panel uh so if you
stop sharing drop sharing